We've seen that 3JS can't easily let us position and rotate the hand of a clock
in place. The problem is that 3Js rotates and then positions when we like to do
these in the opposite order. One simple solution that 3JS provides is to use
Object 3D to make a new object that contains our clock hand. Here's the code for
how to do this. What is happening here is that the block is nested inside the
clock hand object. The translation moves the block so that one end is over the
center of the clock face so that the hand will rotate around the clock properly.
By putting this object into the clock hand, I'm saying that I want to use the
block in its current position. I can then apply an additional scale, rotate and
translate. In this case I just want to rotate. The final line of code adds the
clockHand object to the scene. That's 1 way to look at Object3D. It adds more
transforms into the list that you can then use. We now have some six transforms
that we can set in this system. Here's the conceptual diagram of the whole idea.
We create a block and we can scale, rotate and translate that block. Then by
putting it inside an Object 3D called clockHand, we get an additional scale,
rotate and translate that wen can apply. Here's a more compact way to write out
the order of transforms. The object at scale, rotated and translated and then
scaled, rotated and translated again. This looks a bit crazy, I've put the order
of the transform from right to left. There is a reason for this and we'll talk
about it when we get to matrices. For now just believe me that this is how most
computer graphics text show a series of transforms. The way I remember this
order is by the word trash. There's TRS in that word in the proper notational
order. I guess I could use the word trees instead and not have to worry about
the h, but I like trash, as it reminds me of the TRS80. Called the TRASH 80 for
short, one of the first personal computers. From back when programs were stored
on cassette tapes, once upon a time, this computer ruled the earth. In 1979, it
had the largest selection of software for any PC. Trs then is the order to
remember. In our case, just the boxes translation and the clock hands rotation
are used. This gets us the combination we want. Translates so there's a new
origin and then rotate around this origin. Adding a whole Object 3D to get a
single additional transform seems like overkill, but really it doesn't add much
code.